- I'm glad you're here.
I was going to call you because
I was noticing all the cool
fashion in the city. And
I was wondering like,
what were Tim Gunn's top tips
for conquering New York with
style? Do you maybe have
a few asking for friend?
- Well, I have. I'm
always filled with chips,
um especially what not to do,
- Okay
but also what to do,
And as someone from Los Angeles,
- Yes
I just have to say,
you should never leave home
here without an extra pair of
shoes. It may sound strange,
- Kelly: No it doesn't.
but we're not Los Angeles.
- I see these girls be walking
around in heels and I'm like,
no, we have.
- Subway steps and we
have unpredictable weather
- Nike's
and, were constantly chasing taxis.
So we need good pair of shoes
and we need to be able to
change out on them as well.
- Okay. So you got to carry
those with you in a bag.
- Yes
- Okay. Okay. Check. Okay. Anything else?
- That leads us into our number two item
which is you must have a tote bag
containing all of your needs for the day.
- Done. I'm a woman so.
(echoed laughter)
- But you know, we're walking city.
- Yes
- So we pack up the tote for
what the needs are for that
particular day. And off we go.
- I got you, any other tips?
- Well, yes, and this is called
Just loosening up and feeling free.
- Check
- What I love the most about the city.
- Got it
- What I love most about the
city is that when it comes to
fashion, anything goes,
you can be exuberant and avant-garde,
you can be minimal, and quiet.
This city doesn't judge you for
how you express yourself and how you
present yourself.
(audience cheering)
- I do love that! I love that you can
just walk around the city and you see,
just all walks of life,
all different types of like personalities.
I love that the city embraces that.
Like I came from like a city
where it was very weird to do
like the smallest thing.
Like everybody kind of
looked cookie cutter.
- Tim: Oh Yeah! usually.
So I love, I know,
but I love that. I
think it's so inspiring,
especially just the arts.
I think that, you know,
it's like a,
a flag of like freedom and that
feeling of really being able
to be free and be yourself.
I love that this city is like that.
- I completely agree, the city wants
you to be who you are and
that's a beautiful thing.
- I love that.